non vraiment tu connais l'avait fait toi
à toi tu viens vraiment de me faire la
blague l'avait fait les wc à dans ce
n'est pas une blague
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la bc c'est un peu comme la pls c'est
rentré dans le langage courant on fait
des blagues dessus mais en vrai tout le
monde sait pas forcément ce que c'est
mais comme c'est quand même la première
cause de handicap acquis en dehors des
traumatismes genre accident de la route
ça vaut la peine de se renseigner et
surtout de savoir repérer si quelqu'un
en fer devant jouent alors avc ça veut
dire accident vasculaire cérébral
c'est à dire qu'il ya un problème au
niveau d'un vaisseau chargé d'irriguer
le cerveau et lui apporter l'oxygène et
tout ce dont il a besoin pour
fonctionner correctement
ça peut être un caillot qui bouche un
vaisseau et qui empêche le sang de
passer le caillou peut se former sur
place ou à distance puis se balader dans
la circulation jusqu'à venir se coincer
dans une artère du cerveau plus petit
que les autres dans ce cas là on parle
d'avc ischémique et c'est le cas le plus
fréquent mais ça peut aussi être un
vaisseau qui se met à fuir ou carrément
un vaisseau qui pète on parle alors d'un
avc hémorragique
hélas non seulement le sens ni rick plus
la zone mais en plus le saignement peut
comprimer le cerveau et parce que quand
on a un hématome au niveau du bras par
exemple comme la peau et élastique ça
gonfle mais ça comprime pas trop le
problème c'est qu'au tour du cerveau via
la boîte crânienne que la boîte
crânienne faible hausse que l'os c'est
pas élastique et donc quand ça gonfle sa
comprime le cerveau et le cerveau est
comprimé et aime pas trop ça en plus
quand le cerveau est abîmée non
seulement il a du mal à récupérer
mais comme c'est aussi le siège de
fonction super importante
les conséquences peuvent être graves la
gravité dépend de l'étendue de la zone
qui n'est plus irriguée et sa
localisation donc des fonctions qui sont
atteintes
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que plus vite
en avc pris en charge plus vite il est
soigné et plus on diminue
le risque de séquelles ça fait un paquet
de bonnes raisons de connaître les
signes pour leur père est une des
principales caractéristiques d'un avc
c'est que ces signes apparaissent
brutalement comme un coup de tonnerre
dans un ciel bleu et sachez que la
victime n'a pas forcément conscience de
ces troubles
les signes les plus fréquents sont un
engourdissement ou une paralysie d'une
partie ou de tout un côté du corps c'est
le signe que les cellules nerveuses
chargé de faire passer les informations
concernant les mouvements ont été
touchés si le côté gauche du cerveau et
touché c'est la partie droite du corps
qui ont suivi les conséquences et
inversement
parce que les faisceaux qui transmettent
les informations se croisent échangent
de côté entre le cerveau et la moelle
épinière le visage devient asymétrique
avec notamment un côté de la bouche
citons un des deux bras devient plus
faible avec une difficulté voire une
impossibilité à lever peut aussi toucher
la jambe du même côté et aussi des
troubles de la parole qui apparaissent
la personne a du mal à parler elle peut
employer un mot pour un autre ou
prononcer les syllabes qui ne veulent
rien dire c'est le signe que les zones
du langage ou de la compréhension du
langage ont été touchés d'ailleurs la
victime peut aussi alors du mal à
comprendre ce qu'on lui dit alors ça ce
sont les signes principaux mais ça peut
aussi se manifester par un gros mal de
tête qui apparaît brutalement des
troubles de la vue comme la perte de la
vision d'un oeil ou la vue qui se
trouble et fourmillements dans la moitié
du corps des troubles de l'équilibré et
une démarche pas très stable du coup
comme en plus la personne parle
bizarrement on peut penser qu'elle est
bourré mais en fait non alors peut-être
mais pas seulement si vous avez un doute
je vous donne quelques trucs simples
pour vérifier qu'il s'agit bien d'un avc
demandé à la victime de répéter une
phrase simple pour vérifier si elle a
des troubles du langage
demandez-lui de sourire et tirer la
langue pour vérifier si son visage
devient asymétrique
demandez lui de lever ses bras devant
elle pendant 10
depuis de serre et vos mains pour
vérifier si elle a moins de force d'un
côté que de l'autre vous pouvez aussi
lui demander de lever ses jambes
mais dans ces cas là vous êtes là soir
avant ce serait vraiment pas le bon
alors attention tous ces signes ne sont
pas toujours présents mais même si vous
n'en repéré qu'un seul et surtout s'il
est apparu brutalement prévenu les
secours
en attendant qu'ils arrivent rassurer la
victime bon alors ok vu les
circonstances a pas forcément être
facile mais si elle s'agite elle risque
de faire monter sa tension et ça risque
d'aggraver les choses dites lui que vous
gérez que les secours vont arriver
qu'elle va être prise en charge et qu'il
faut qu'elles soient le plus calme
possible pour que tout se passe bien
si la victime est consciente allonger la
dans une position confortable avec un
oreiller sous la tête et noter toutes
les informations importantes pour les
secours comme l'heure de début des
troubles
si vous êtes chez elle cherchait ses
ordonnances ou son dossier médical ça
pourra aussi être très utile de la fête
ni manger ni boire et ne la laissez pas
prendre ses médicaments
si la personne est inconsciente mettez
la en pls alors on en a déjà parlé mais
n'hésitez pas à vous former
petite précision important parfois les
signes peuvent être discret et la
victime peut récupérer complètement dans
la foulée c'est ce qu'on appelle un
accident ischémique transitoire ou une
ischémie cérébrale transitoire
ça veut dire qu'un vaisseau s'est bouché
puis ses débouchés mais ça reste une
urgence notamment parce qu'un avc peut
se constituer par la suite donc appelé
les secours dans tous les cas si vous
avez un doute appeler le samu au 15 ou
le numéro d'appel d'urgence européen au
112 vous tomberez sur des gens
spécialement formée qui vous diront
exactement quoi faire
et n'ayez pas peur de mal faire la seule
façon de mal faire à coup sûr c'est de
ne rien faire
voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
comme d'habitude je vous mets des liens
dans la description on se retrouve très
vite pour des nouvelles vidéos alors
abonnez vous faudra être sûr de rien
louper 1 d'ici là ce que je vous propose
bas mettez vous bien et puis surtout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]